going completely off topic here but
there's been one video one video of mine
recently
oh yeah that's just been [ __ ] getting
recommended to everyone
and i have no idea why it's an
eight-year-old video
that we've not talked about in this
podcast so many people have tweeted us
about it i'm just like
wow yeah so there's been a video
recently that's been circulating that's
called
recently the time of filming yeah
recently at the time of filming um
it might still be circulating talking
about it it's probably going to start
getting
so i should probably circle back to the
start of annie tube itself you guys are
about to get a history lesson here
go on so okay so do you do you guys know
who the very first annie tuber is
i thought it was mr anime yeah that was
my preconception yeah
i mean i'd be surprised if anyone
watching this new because that means
you've been around for as long as me
but the very first anime youtuber is
this guy called
hard anime reviews okay and he would be
he started in 2006 and he would just
basically make he would basically make
very uh
very basic anime reviews with like his
camera was like up here
worst angle yeah yeah they're kind of
kind of like the worst angle you can
think of the angle we all start
right and he he's not he's now quit um
it's it's funny because i
i tried to search him up and see if he's
still around and he
his first his first original channel got
terminated as everyone's did
back then when they were reviewing anime
and his second channel
is called unironically the hard mode
he called it the hard mode and okay if
you search this on youtube you have to
you have to search
the hard mode no space otherwise you're
not going to find it because
it's it's like that buried within the
search yeah search algorithm
but the second annie tuber was this
person called mr anime
and um he was he basically made his
anime youtube channel
to compete with hard because hard was
the only anime youtube channel around
and then mr anime was the second one and
he really at the time he really was
one of the big faces of anime youtube
and i say big
he had like a thousand subscribers
that's what i mean [ __ ] though back in
the day yeah that is big [ __ ] back in
2006 2007.
yeah yeah and then it was after mr anime
that there were like there were like
some some other anime channels here and
there but those two
are basically the founding fathers of
anitu okay
they're we we have we have them to thank
for where we are now basically if people
know
the ending to the story then you know
how funny that statement is
i know right so then after a while i um
i make my youtube channel
and i i do i do my own thing and the
very
very first shout out i got was from a mr
anime video
and it's it's still up which video is it
huh it's it's mr anime it's it's
his channel store yeah his channel is
all stuff you can view
his entire history and everything that
he did wow that's weird because
who's that guy recently who got
prosecuted for like child pornography
and they took down his channel like that
oh really yeah that austin guy the
singing guy
we picture on screen uh yeah i don't
know
because i i remember a couple of months
ago uh i it
a mr anime video like popped up wow wow
just randomly yeah anyway
yeah sorry yeah yeah no so mr anime the
first time he shouted me out was just he
made a video
like i think it was called like the face
of annie any tube or anime youtube or
something and he just shouted out a
bunch of
og anime reviews back in the day what a
nice yeah
so so so that was the very first
boost in subscribers i got and i'm
messaging him being like oh
thanks a lot man like that that really
helped me out they got me like 300
subscribers
like holy [ __ ] that was that was a lot
back in that yeah i think that was the
video that pushed me over my first
thousand subscribers nice which was a
big which was a big [ __ ] deal so i
was
i was really happy and i really
respected the guy as well because
you know he was if not if not for him
if not for him like i probably you know
i'd probably be less confident to do
what i
did on like validation yeah yeah and
especially
you know no matter what whenever you see
someone bigger than you shouting you out
that's that's like a big pat on the back
oh yeah yeah yeah
i did well so i was like and he messing
with me back being like nah that's no
problem bro
like i just lo i just like i just really
like your stuff you know i congratulate
he couldn't even pronounce my name back
then i think in the video he called me
guy gick no i didn't say that now
they're all gonna call you guys
so that was the last kind of interaction
i had with him
um and that's your first and last
interaction yeah that was that was my
first and last interaction
uh back then the anime youtube community
wasn't we knew we bought each other but
we didn't
talk about talk to each other that much
it's just before like the msm
days yes yeah yes so
there wasn't an easy way to talk to each
other apart from
back when youtube had messaging you know
i remember
remember those days remember yeah
youtube dms
which were slowly just phased out of
existence i guess
and just nobody remembers that you could
message you could dm people on youtube
but one day um i
just i just woke up and i had this
message from this other anime youtuber
who was called iko arisaka 420 who's
also like
yeah yeah yeah jesus christ i know the
entire history of anime youtube right
right here
right here um and he he was like he
he was he asked me if i'd heard about
this article that's been
like linked around and it was this
article that
was this police report that basically
just said trey sessler
has been arrested for the murdering his
family i'm like yeah well well is is
this
trey sessler the anime man the same
trace tesla
we got him out folks we got him out of
prison
oh
oh my god i can't believe i blanked on
the name mid-story
but um why did you have me like that
yeah yeah i i clicked on the article and
he had his face
and that was just uh just the oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah is is this is this real like
how how i
i had like 50 different emotions yeah i
cannot just just seeing because
you don't know how to react to this
because the more i read
just the more sickening it got yeah so
the the entire the entire story
was that apparently traceless trey
sessler mr anime
had uh been playing around with his
brother
and they they were playing around with
guns as they did on that as they did
see he had a lot of guns in in like his
channel and everything but
you know me back then me back then i
just think
americans guns that's what just that's
just what they do
that's what british people think about
it yeah we literally think the americans
just walk around being like i don't know
so he would just have guns in his anime
reviews i just thought that was
completely normal which
you know because he was from texas as
well he was from texas
he was like slinging texas yeah exactly
so i was like this is this is completely
normal this is nothing to worry about
and
you know but there's a text and watching
this video with that gun just like
even even now even now i see a text him
with a gun
i just think you know that's that's even
normal even after everything i'm just
about to experience but i i read the
story and
he was playing around with his guns with
his brother and apparently he
accidentally
shot his brother and he and he killed
him
and so he didn't the the official story
that he gave was he didn't want
his parents to feel guilt or his family
to feel guilt
about you know having his having their
son
kill one of their brothers so he just
apparently he just thought might as well
[ __ ] kill them all
which is which is [ __ ] awful
which is which is [ __ ] awful which is
a [ __ ] awful conclusion to come to so
apparently he kills
his entire family and then and then it
gets worse
because the like the more information
that comes out
the more um we find out that he was
actually
not only planning to kill his family
anyway
but he was actually planning a columbine
style
school shooting yeah right i've cause i
saw like this
really good documentary on youtube i'm
sure it's up there still rainbot right
yeah i think so it's
it's basically covers the whole thing
but that's how i got all my information
as well
where yeah he was planning to do a
school shooting and
he i did he post about it online that he
was going to do it or something like
that but he basically
was on the way to the school and that's
when he got arrested yeah yeah
no because he was he was planning he was
planning the school shooting for way
before he's killed his family because i
i think
i think how he thought was he killed his
brother by accident but
he was always planning the school
shooting anyway yeah like
he had he had it all mapped out and
everything so in between that he
accidentally killed his brother and
killed his family and that's what outed
him
but he was always planning this and
there's this really ominous video
um it was i think it's the second to
last mr anime video that's on his
channel that's just called
mr anime is planning something and
i remember watching that thinking ah
he's he's taking a break from annie
i'm just planning a new review he's he's
planning a cut he's planning a comeback
but i don't know it's it because he
talks about anime in that video so he
might he might have been just
purely talking about anime but i'm i'm
like with all the information i have we
have now he's probably now that
was [ __ ] scary [ __ ] that title was
[ __ ] yeah
and the more information that come that
came out the more
i just didn't know how to process this
because how how do you process the fact
that
one of the people you looked up to and
respected just [ __ ] killed their
family and was planning to shoot up a
[ __ ] school
like what what what what'd you do with
that yeah and
that bothered me for uh for for like a
for a while yeah and i remember that's
this was the time i was at university
and people were like why why is
why does god look like someone just died
in his family or something
but i i think the way the best way i can
describe it is
imagine if you like live in a small town
and you you may be like you know
everyone in that small town you might
not be friends with everyone small town
but you feel like this
small tight-knit community and then you
find that someone in this small
tiny community has done something awful
yeah
it's like something that's not like
beyond words you know beyond words awful
and it's and
then to try to process process this i
i made the video which is being
recommended now
it's circulating everywhere even though
it's eight years old
um it's for some reason youtube decided
yep
people want to see gang reacting to mr
anime murdering his family
i i don't i don't know how that came
about it's literally on everyone's
recommended it was on my recommended
i think connor said it was on tv yeah
yeah like and it's it's like
yeah i don't know why like yeah it's
probably not monetized right
no no it's not like right so it's just
like it just goes against
everything about the youtube algorithms
like it's not monetized it's about a
horrible tragedy it's about a very
sensitive topic i mean i'm eight years
old i i think i
uploaded this before even like the
monetization thing like started on
youtube or at least before i was
monetized because i was
i had like a thousand plus subscribers
back then so
it was it wasn't massive i remember as
well that i
i i remember stumbling upon a mr anime
video even
like way before i knew about the whole
anime youtubing sphere
and everything because it was mr anime's
review on gantz that made me want to go
watch games
and uh this guy's got a bright career
yeah and i was like wow this guy's like
really
he [ __ ] had do you know how ghetto
his setup was he he had like a a a
webcam or something yeah yeah yeah to
record and he was sitting on his bed and
he had
his lap it was like a notepad oh it was
like an apple an apple notebook it was
like an apple notepad of the script and
he was literally just looking down
at the apple notepad just reading off
the script and then every now and then
i guess because he didn't know how to
edit his videos so instead he had
a remote that controlled the zoom of the
lens
he controlled the zoom of the lens and
he just started talking to the camera
and then he just zoomed back out yeah
no cuts so he was like i remember in the
gantt's review
he was talking about uh you know the
acid scene right yeah and the dance
anime
and how he was like it made me go and
then he stops and zooms in
and zooms really far into his face and
he goes [ __ ]
and then he zooms out with a dead face
and he just goes back to reading it
yeah and that was the review no cuts no
edits
and i was like yeah i want to watch this
anime i mean that was quality content
back in the day or valley tube
i remember when i started coming out
with my videos i was one of the first to
actually just
use an editing software even though it
was just putting images over whatever
i'm saying i was like people like
what he's he's using windows movie maker
impossible
wow but yeah that's that's the story of
the first person i ever in
like humble beginnings yeah that's so
funny
yeah but i i recommend like as [ __ ] of
uh of a topic that is like i
i'd definitely recommend that
documentary on youtube that somebody
made oh it's great because it perfectly
goes through everything about it
and at the end of the documentary i
don't know how they got this footage but
there's this
the police footage the police footage of
how he's in like the jail cell yeah
yeah the interview that [ __ ] is so scary
man yeah
and to think this is the guy who founded
basically what i do for a living i know
i know right right like that's so
[ __ ] scary
it's it's so weird because i've had a
con i've had this conversation with a
few people and
we just think man there's a lot of [ __ ]
that's happened in any tubes yeah
right i think there's stuff that
unfortunately you know
happens in every community yeah and that
we probably will never find out
some really [ __ ] up [ __ ] that people
have done oh yeah i mean
we've only recently found out about a
lot of it right right right i mean you
know you
you it's it's really unfortunate because
we don't like to think that we know
people who are like that
but if that time's proven anything it's
that
you know i've i've nev met people and
been friendly with people who have done
really [ __ ] horrible stuff
i'm sure i mean i never knew that you
know one of my best friends used to
punch kids in the face hey that's not
bad
those kids they punched me first and
then [ __ ]
i mean once you look once you look up
and respect a [ __ ]
serial killer school shooter then it's
all downhill from there right yeah
exactly i i know how it feels to see a
police report and being like oh
no i i remember i just
it's just a mess of emotions it's first
it's
surely this is fake you see it and
you're like i've never seen a place
before first of all
yeah yeah this could easily be doctored
like yeah yeah and then just seeing like
all the counts
being slowly like added and you're like
oh no yeah oh no
oh no this is bad yeah and i think that
that was the first time
because i had a conversation with aiko
arasaka the
the anime review about how we should
process this and remember him saying
um yeah i think he just he'll keep the
memories of mr anime like the same but
it's just he has to view mr anime and
trey sessler as like
different people and i think that was
the first time the first time i
i had just thought about the entire
process of
having to view online personalities as
different
in person how they portray this the
whole thing of like separating the
artist from the creation
yeah yeah exactly right it's and yeah
the
it was more the fact that this happened
in our small community as well because
right it's like happening in like the
small back rural town right when nothing
happens because i'm sure now in any tube
i'm sure there's
some [ __ ] somewhere oh there's
probably some someone doing so we don't
despicable [ __ ] that we don't know about
you know but
it they weren't a figurehead in this
very small community
they weren't the [ __ ] founding
the more you say that out loud the more
i'm like oh the founding fathers tend to
normally be
sketchy how do we sell that the anime
youtube
community is like this really cool thing
oh the family father's a serial killer
that's a conversation starter i like to
think of it of you know it's
it's one of those things that was going
to be started anyway eventually around
that time yeah
it just so happened that he was the
first or one of the first maybe that's
the reason why nobody
used anime in the username until i came
up because
people because i know for a fact that
some of my early videos
man those comments were just like the
anime man i thought that guy went to
jail
like they legitimately
flashback to five minutes